pour mais également exceptionnel je vais
tout de suite laissé la parole au
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner pour vous présenter le décret
que nous avons examiné aujourd'hui puis
je reprendrai la main pour répondre à
toutes vos questions
merci madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs hier le président
de la république a annoncé une série de
décisions supplémentaires dans notre
guerre face au co vide 19 ans et qu'en
conséquence ce matin un conseil des
ministres a été convoquée où il a été
présenté un projet de décret simple pris
en conseil des ministres qui permet
d'abroger la convocation des électeurs
pour le second tour des élections
municipales
initialement prévu le 22 mars la
décision de retarder ce second tour des
élection concerne trente mille deux cent
cinquante trois communes du conseil
municipal a été partiellement pour lui
et 1669 commune où aucun conseil
municipal n'a été élu à l'issue du
premier tour qui compte 1000 autres
communes est issue du premier tour
constitué le conseil municipal celui ci
pour se réunir vendredi ou samedi pour
désigner son exécutif démocratie chacun
le sait cette décision et ça vous le
prise comptabilité on sen sus
scientifiques conseillant la tenue du
second tour du scrutin est aussi sur le
consensus politique appelant au report
du scrutin dans le cadre des
consultations initiées et porté par le
premier ministre devenant le nouveau
conseil des ministres ce décret sera
complété par un projet de loi qui est
examiné au moment où je vous parle le
conseil d'état messieurs je voudrais
aussi devant vous abordez un second
point celui de la mise en oeuvre des
mesures annoncées par le président de la
république hier soir minutes il sera
midi
et je l'ena a annoncé hier soir des
mesures de confinement strict les plus
strictes d'europe seront mises en oeuvre
j'en ai détaillait le contenu permettez
moi de préciser à nouveau ces mesures
qui doivent absolument être connue de
nos concitoyens pour être respecté les
règles sont simples mais la règle
générale est plus simple encore rester
chez vous c'est cycle vous pourrez aider
à couper la propagation du virus
c'est un personnel soignant et à notre
système de santé c'est ici que vous
serez au fil de notre gueule contre le
coc vide
19 c'est pourquoi à partir de midi et
pour durer deux jours qui pourrait être
proche en fonction de l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire tous les déplacements
doivent être réduits à leur strict
minimum
je le répète restez chez vous
aujourd'hui et dans les prochains jours
c'est sauver des vies bien sûr quelques
exceptions peuvent être tolérés je les
énoncés hier soir je le répète
aujourd'hui car nous avons besoin de cet
instant depuis quitté et le pédagogie
placement entre le domicile et le
travail notamment pour les personnes
dont les activités ne peut être
interrompue y gagnent ise sous forme de
télétravail par tous pour les produits
de première nécessité c'est à dire la
nourriture ou les produits d'hygiène
pour des motifs de santé évidemment et
aller à la pharmacie mais j'évite les
français il n'en est que toutes les
pharmacies resteront ouvertes pendant la
totalité de la durée ou les mesures que
je viens d'évoquer seront mises en
oeuvre vous précipitez pas dans les
pharmacies et cela ne sert à rien et
contribue au désordre aussi et menacent
le bon fonctionnement de notre système
de pharmacie dans notre pays mais aussi
des exceptions sont aussi prévues pour
les déplacements en serbie
atif je dis bien longtemps impératif
impératif par exemple l'assistance aux
personnes vulnérables et je citais aussi
comme exemple hier soir celui de parents
divorcés qui peuvent naturellement
toujours aller chercher ou retrouver
leur enfant et ma dernière exception qui
doit être bien comprise comme
exceptionnel se sont dépassés très bref
à proximité immédiate du domicile afin
de faire du sport ou pour promener son
chien
il conviendra je le répète de limiter au
maximum les sorties et toutes activités
collectives elles restent et elles sont
interdites
des exemples concrets
laurent hâtât famille les dîneurs pris
le foot avec quelques 2000 on trouve et
pour une partie de cartes
tout ce qui peut paraître anodin en
temps normal et tout perdre y
déconseillait c'est interdit chacune de
ces rencontres
ne négligez pas cela c'est une
possibilité de transmettre le virus
c'était que de contribuer c'est l'airé à
la diffusion du code vip 19 derrière
chaque poignée de main chez beez chaque
rencontre
en gros ce sont des victimes de plus ce
sont des morts de plus les agripper sont
importants la décision est difficile
mais nous le prenons en responsabilité
de vie et de mort imminent au fond de
difficultés à comprendre cette règle
chacun peut s'engager pour son pays de
s'engager pour les autres la règle est
simple il suffit de rester chez soi
confinement montre ses effets et en big
effectivement la propagation du virus
nous avons décidé de moyens adaptés pour
en éviter qu'ils ne sont pas respectés
et pourront vérifier l'application
scrupuleuse pour chaque sortie
chaque jeune devra disposer d'une
attestation sur l'honneur indiquant son
identité
son adresse est le motif de son
déplacement
tous les acteurs qui disposent de moyens
de diffusion numérique mais aussi des
attestations ces attestations simple le
déplacement dérogatoire j'habite aussi
celles et ceux qui ne peuvent pas les
imprimés et les reproduire sur papier
libre
elles sont efficaces mais elles devront
être rédigées pour chaque déplacement
d'attestation de déplacement était aussi
mise en place en ligne sur le ministère
de l'intérieur et sera complétée par une
autorisation signée par l'employeur pour
s'exercer eux qui doivent se déplacer
dans le cadre professionnel
un autre formulaire la professionnelle
doit aussi être diffusé le plus
largement et j'appelle chacune et chacun
à nous aider dans cette diffusion
au moment où je vous parle et depuis
hier soir
cent mille policiers et gendarmes sont
en cours de déplacement sur
l'intégralité du territoire national ils
ont pour mission de vérifier que chaque
personne soit en possession de son
attestation en cas de sortie ils
réaliseront aussi des contrôles aussi
bien fixe qu'aléatoire sur les réseaux
de transport il s'intégre ont pour les
contrôles de véhicules pour les
contrôles en matière de transport
collectif mais aussi pour les piétons
nous nous tenons prêts à sanctionner
mais 38 euros aujourd'hui est prévue son
montant sera rapidement porté à 135
euros pour mettre en oeuvre les
décisions du président de la république
annoncé hier la cellule
interministérielle de crise est mise en
place sur décision du premier ministre
le suivi constant du respect des mesures
de confinement et de l'ordre public la
sécurité de nos concitoyens mais aussi
sécurité des frontières et à la
continuité de l'état des aspects
sanitaires restent assurées par le
ministère de la santé
elles sortent en quelques minutes
installée parti premier ministre le
ministre de la santé et de la solidarité
et par moi-même je voudrais vous dire
que la limitation drastique des
déplacements doit-être coupure à goutte
et global concerne donc évidemment aussi
les déplacements transfrontaliers
c'est donc
en concertation étroite avec nos
homologues présidents de la commission
et que le président de la république a
décidé de mettre en oeuvre les
propositions présiderez ursula von der
leyen la prison de résolution européenne
ainsi désormais toutes les entrées des
ressortissants étrangers à l'union
européenne à l'espace schengen et
royaume uni sont interdites au sein de
l'espace européen dans des pays tiers
les frontières seront fermés quelques
exceptions sont prévues les
ressortissants de pays tiers avec un
permis de séjour ambigu pourront par
exemple rentrer dans l'union je suis
répété aussi que la circulation de
marchandises se poursuit cette mesure
est à 70 contraignante mais nécessaire
pour bloquer la pandémie
concernant les frontières de l'europe
enfin deux mesures ont été prises ces
derniers jours notre objectif n'est pas
de fermer les frontières mais de limiter
au maximum les déplacements non
impératif
des contrôles sont et seront donc mis en
place nos frontières et les personnes ce
déplacement pour des motifs qui l'ont
indispensable devront faire demi tour je
les dis hier soir et je le répète à
nouveau devant vous cette mesure ne
concerne pas les travailleurs
transfrontaliers qui vont vous continuez
à traverser la frontière en présentant
les justificatifs de domicile mais aussi
nécessaire elle ne concerne plus les
transports de marchandises et nous avons
évidemment d'un approvisionnement
continu pendant cette paix des ministres
donc pas de crainte à avoir pour les
approvisionnements en denrées
alimentaires et en matériel de soins
concernant nos frontières sont
cohérentes à notre volonté de limiter au
maximum les deux placements de chacun
elles sont aussi transitoire bien sûr
elle vous mettre un frein à la
propagation du coc u19
voilà mesdames et messieurs les quelques
points que je souhaitais présenter à
vous à l'issue de ce conseil des
ministres
je vous le rappelle notre mot d'ordre
est un modèle qui sauve des vies
restez chez vous merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre je vous libère puisque vous
devez justement installé la cellule
interministérielle de crise en présence
du premier ministre
mais un autre témoin du coup de
reprendre le cours habituel de ce
compte-rendu cassis rituel
vu la configuration de ce cours du
conseil des ministres en vous faisant
part de l'introduction du président de
la république à l'occasion de ce conseil
des ministres bic a donc commencé son
propos aux relents comme il avait eu
l'occasion de le faire hier que nous
étions dans une situation de guerre
sanitaires cette bien sanitaires à
d'autres nous permettre de freiner
l'expansion d'un ennemi invisible
le virus qui donnent aujourd'hui lieu à
une épidémie la l'épidémie de
coronavirus autre objectif dans la
période qui s'ouvre et qui se déploie
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines et
de tout faire pour que les personnes les
plus fragiles dans notre société mais
également les soignants soit le mieux
protégé possible nous faisons face
aujourd'hui à une situation d'épidémie
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
mais avec une forte circulation très
forte circulation du virus dans le grand
est
en ile de france et dans les hauts de
france il existe deux types de stratégie
nous a rappelé prises dans la république
pour faire face à cette à ce type de
pandémie
d'aucuns considèrent qu'il faut laisser
circuler le virus pourrait laisser une
immunité naturelle se développer dans
une population ce n'est pas le choix que
nous faisons bien au contraire
nous souhaitons que il y ait à travers
une réduction des contacts sociaux un
lissage du pic de l'épidémie qui
permettra à notre système sanitaire
parce qu'il ya dans de bonnes conditions
tous ceux qui en auront besoin
notre objectif est donc de la rappeler
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
république il s'agit à la fois de
protéger les français sur le plan
sanitaire bien sûr c'est ce que nous
faisons au quotidien
autour du ministre de la santé des
solidarités olivier ferrand mais aussi
sur le plan économique et social et en
articulation avec les différents
ministres de bercy vous avez pu le
constater de nombreuses mesures ont été
prises de court terme pour permettre de
passer ce choc économique
le président de la république a rappelé
également que nous étions très attachés
à la continuité de la vie démocratique
de notre pays et c'est pour cela que sur
la base du consensus à la fois
scientifique et politique de la semaine
dernière nous avions décidé la tenue du
premier tour des élections des élections
municipales
ce consensus pour tenir les élections
aujourd'hui est un consensus qui va vers
la non tenue des élections municipales
pour le second tour et comme l'a indiqué
le ministre de l'intérieur à l'instant
nous avons pris ce matin le décret qui
permet de reporter ces élections
l'objectif qui est le nôtre dans les
semaines à venir sera de gérer une
situation inédite cette situation
inédite elle nécessitera sans doute des
ajustements au fur et à mesure je
comprend parfois que les français se
demandent comment est-ce que les choses
doivent se dérouler exactement puisse
avoir le sentiment que il y adeux
l'imprécision ou du flou cette situation
inédite et exceptionnelle elle nécessite
que nous disions systématiquement et en
toute transparence et ce à quoi et c'est
ce à quoi nous a appelé le président de
la république que nous donne des
explications fois aussi que nous
ajustions en fonction des remontées du
terrain ce que nous n'aurons pas de
faire à chaque instant
le président la république pour conclure
a également souhaité que dans le moment
que nous vivions nous puissions d'ores
et déjà penser à la suite et il a
souhaité qu'en parallèle des mesures
d'urgence que nous prenons aujourd'hui
sur le plan économique et social nous
puissions d'ores et déjà réfléchir à la
manière dont soutiendront notre économie
en sortie de la crise sanitaire mais
également économique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il enfin pour
conclure appelé l'ensemble des ministres
du gouvernement
à
l'exemplarité l exemplarité parce que
dans la période que nous vivons nos
concitoyens doivent savoir non seulement
que le gouvernement est à la tâche
concentrer pour gérer cette crise
sanitaire inédite mais également que
nous nous appliquons les mêmes principes
qu'ils soient sanitaire de vie sociale
que l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
il a enfin et je conclurai par la
souhaiter très vivement remerciés de
leur mobilisation l'ensemble des
français qu'ils soient dans les services
publics qu'ils soient dans les grandes
administrations de l'état n'est qu'il
soit aussi ces français qui dans les
commerces de proximité
ceux qui doivent rester ouverts
aujourd'hui pour assurer la continuité
de notre vie son église et sont à la
tâche parfois avec de la peur mais
toujours au service des autres voilà ce
que je peux vous dire de l'introduction
du président de la république à
l'occasion de ce conseil des ministres
et je suis à la disposition de la
représentante de la presse
présidentielle pour répondre aux
questions qui pourraient être posées
bonjour mr une vasque de bfmtv
effectivement je vais me faire le porte
parole de mes confrères puisque le
confinement s'applique à 6 aussi à nous
j'ai une première question concernant
justement ces mesures de confinement
cent mille policiers déployés sur tout
le territoire en revanche pas de
contrôles systématiques
est ce que si à nouveau on voit que ces
mesures ne sont pas strictement appliqué
le gouvernement pourrait passer à une
mesure encore plus strict avec peut-être
un couvre feu ou des contrôles
systématiques alors mon envisageons pas
à ce stade de couvre-feu ce que nous
souhaitons à travers une présence
policière et de gendarmes qui soit
visible c'est que nos concitoyens
puissent prendre conscience que il y a
quelque chose qui a changé véritablement
dans
dans la situation et qui nécessite pour
eux un changement de comportement et
donc on aura évidemment de la part des
policiers des gendarmes de la pédagogie
qui sera réalisée mais nous aurons aussi
de la coercition pas tout de suite le
temps de laisser tout le monde prendre
ses marques
mais très rapidement il s'agira de faire
en sorte que ceux qui ne respectent pas
les préconisations qui sont les nôtres
soient sanctionnés nous avons d'ores et
déjà une amende de 38 euros qui peut
s'appliquer et les susceptibles de
monter jusqu'à 135 euros
c'est à dire que dès maintenant l'aller
12h24 les policiers ne font pas de
pédagogie il sanctionne non vous le
disais nous devons laisser du temps aux
français pour s'habituer à cette
nouvelle donne est donc je ne peux pas
vous dire exactement à la minute près
dans combien de temps on commencera à
mettre des amendes effective ce qui est
important à comprendre c'est que la
consigne de rester chez soi plus elle
s'applique et plus vite nous avons de
chances d'abord d'en sortir
mais aussi de gagner cette course contre
la montre pour freiner la propagation et
la transmission du coronavirus pour les
professionnels qui sont obligés de
sortir comme les policiers les
personnels soignants beaucoup
s'inquiétaient de ne pas être équipés en
masques notamment chez les policiers en
masques gants est ce que le nécessaire a
été fait pour eux qui doivent continuer
à être dans les rues alors d'abord je
voudrais rappeler rappelé que les modes
de transmission du coronavirus sont
essentiellement des transmissions par
mouthe let et donc il faut être dans une
forme de proximité avec les gens
pourquoi cette transmission se fasse
c'est essentiellement par des mains
souillées
parce qu'on n'a pas tousser dans son
coude mais tous et dans ses mains ou
éternuer dans ses mains que nous avons
des mains qui contiennent pas une
proportion importante de virus et que
donc par le fait de se toucher
on peut transmettre le virus la
transmission n'est pas rien pour le
coronavirus et donc l'utilisation la
doctrine d'emploi comme on dit dans le
jargon des masques de protection qui a
été affinée par les professionnels de
santé nous conduit d'abord à prioriser
ces professionnels de santé parce que
nous savons que cette première ligne de
soignants si elle n'est pas au rendez
vous si elle est elle même troupe
infectés par le corona virus parce que
je sais que malheureusement de par leur
vie de tous les jours d'autres les
soignants peuvent être infectés nous
savons peu
nous allons au devant de graves
difficultés priorité est aujourd'hui que
les soignants puisse disposer de ces
masques des camions circulent en ce
moment partout en france pour aller là
où pour aller déposer des masques dans
des pharmacies c'était l'engagement du
président de la république lors de son
allocution télévisée donc dès ce soir et
jusqu'à jeudi
cette distribution de masques dans les
officines aura lieu et permettra en
priorité aux professionnels de santé de
pouvoir être pourvus un masque et donc
d'être ainsi protégés ont dit ces
masques doivent être réservée par
priorité pour l'hôpital et pour la
médecine de ville
cette doctrine d'emploi elle nécessite
aussi de gérer un stock de leu géré par
ci une parcimonieusement pour que nous
puissions nous inscrire dans la durée et
donc cette doctrine d'emploi
elle s'applique à l'ensemble des
français c'est à dire que les français
qui vont se précipiter dans les
pharmacies
lorsqu'ils vont vous entendre pour
récupérer des masques ils ne seront pas
prioritaires et pourront imaginer nous
mêmes non les français ne pourront pas
acheter de masse dans les pharmacies
parce que ce n'est pas nécessaire quand
on n'est pas malade sa c'est la première
chose et donc il doit y avoir une
prescription médicale qui fait que vous
pouvez avoir des masques le cas échéant
et de toute façon des pour que vous êtes
susceptible d'être infecté par le pot
vide 19 nous vous demandons de rester
chez vous 2 restreint de vos
déplacements
au grand maximum et ça n'est que dans
l'hypothèse où ne vous pourriez pas
faire votre monde qu'il faut sortir ça
c'est la règle de base par la cie le qui
se monte aujourd'hui à 110 millions de
masques et que nous avons pu renforcer
grâce à la réquisition que nous avons
effectués ce ses stocks de masques et
servent en priorité aux soignants la
doctrine d'emploi pour ce qui est des
forces de l'ordre pour revenir sur ce
sujet là c'est que les masques sont
utiles que dès lors que vous êtes en
proximité immédiate avec pendant sept
policiers gendarmes avec quelqu'un qui
est susceptible d'être infecté ocvidh 19
une question sur les municipales
maintenant de mes confrères du figaro et
pays notamment donald trump un d'une
d'une épidémie probable encore en juin
et en juillet en août 6 me mais lorsque
le conseil scientifique se réunit et que
les les
on dira que les l'urgence sanitaire est
encore chez nous est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que le deuxième tour des
élections municipales ne se passe pas en
juin et dans ce cas-là quid du premier
tour le processus que nous suivons est
très simple nous avons souhaité que les
élections municipales puisse être
reporté puisque il ya désormais un
consensus à la fois sanitaire
scientifiques et politiques pour que ce
soit le cas et donc nous fixons une date
au cours du mois de juin
idéalement le 21 juin mais je ne peux
pas vous assurer de cette date mais
l'idée c'est de repousser ce second tour
au mois de juin afin de nous assurer que
ce second tour se passera dans de bonnes
conditions
nous demanderons un rapport au conseil
scientifique qui sera communiquée au
parlement et qui a vocation à mesurer si
vous font la tenue de ces élections
alors que nous serons mi-mai au mois de
juin pourra se faire effectivement dans
l'hypothèse où ça ne serait pas le cas
et qu'il y aurait à nouveau ce consensus
sanitaires politiques et scientifiques
nous disant qu'on peut pas tenir les
élections nous serions amenés à prendre
des dispositions législatives pour
repousser encore plus loin
les élections municipales ça pourrait
être par exemple à l'automne mais je ne
me place pas encore dans cette situation
nous verrons au mois de mai ce qu'il en
sera de la situation sanitaire du pays
une question maintenant de pallaro tour
ou deux quotidiens dans une interview au
monde l'ancien ministre de la santé
toujours candidate à la mairie de paris
des manuels macron agnès buzyn dit le 11
janvier
j'ai envoyé un message au président sur
la situation le 30 janvier j'avertis
edouard philippe que les élections ne
pourraient sans doute pas se tenir
on aurait dû tout arrêter c'était une
mascarade que lui répondez vous eh bien
je lui réponds que d'abord je veux
saluer l'engagement qu'elle a eu en tant
que ministre du gouvernement
puisque elle a eu l'occasion elle même
en responsabilité de mettre en place les
premiers éléments d'organisation autour
de la gestion de cette crise avant de
renoncer à ses fonctions ministérielles
pour se présenter à la mairie de paris
dans le cadre des élections municipales
ont eu de cesse depuis le début de cette
crise de prendre toujours au fond les
mêmes principes d'abord un principe de
transparence
l'ensemble des décisions que nous avons
prises nous les avons explicité
largement quotidiennement avec le
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon à l'époque avec agnès buzyn puis
par la suite avec avec olivier ferrand
nous sommes astreints à cet exercice de
transparence
le deuxième principe que nous avons mis
en oeuvre c'est de toujours
systématiquement demander un avis
scientifique je vous le disais et je
crois que le président ce comité
scientifique aura l'occasion d'ailleurs
lui-même de le dire comme il a déjà eu
l'occasion de le faire la semaine
dernière que nous avons considéré sur la
base d'un avis scientifiques mais aussi
sur la base d'un consensus politique que
les élections municipales pouvait se
tenir dans de bonnes conditions
la stratégie qui a été la nôtre ça a été
de faire en sorte que ça puisse se faire
dans de bonnes conditions donc
l'application des gestes barrières le
fait que la mise à disposition de points
d'eau pour se laver les mains ou de gel
hydro alcoolique a permis la tenue de
ces élections dans de bonnes conditions
et j'ai envie de vous dire quand je
regarde les images qu'on a pu avoir sur
les réseaux sociaux de jean serrés comme
des sardines dans des parcs vertu ce les
images qu'on a pu avoir dans les bureaux
de vote s'il y avait un endroit où il y
avait un mètre de distance entre les
français c'était typiquement dans les
bureaux de vote où ces règles ont été
scrupuleusement respectée par ailleurs
notre volonté à tueur était de nos entre
deux noms
de nommer dans une stratégie de
graduation qui est aussi alimentée
depuis plusieurs semaines par la
connaissance scientifique que nous avons
du colis de 19
je donnerai un exemple sur le sujet de
la démo de transmission est donc
l'adaptation de notre doctrine d'emploi
des masques
nous avons des informations qui nous ont
permis de comprendre que la transmission
elle ne se faisait pas par l'air mais
par gouttelettes qui nous a permis
d'adapter la réponse sanitaire que nous
avions sur l'utilisation de ces masques
donc systématiquement principes de
transparence et d'information en
direction du grand public et en
direction des professionnels de santé
mais également de principe d'adossement
à des recommandations sanitaires
scientifique de l'ensemble de nos
décisions
mais nous assumons parfaitement les
décisions que nous avons prises sur ce
confinement qui débute là depuis à 32
minutes
un de mes confrères de bfm tv demande
pourquoi une liste claire des métiers
n'a pas été fait c'est à dire que le
flou ne risque-t-il pas de rendre les
mesures de confinement moins efficace
alors peut-être qu'il est effectivement
nécessaire et je comprends parce que
c'est une situation inédite que personne
n'a jamais connu que les choses ne
soient pas forcément évidente à
comprendre dès le début nous demandons
aux français de rester chez eux
cela signifie que lorsqu'ils peuvent
télétravail et ils télétravail
cela signifie que lorsqu'il ne bouffe
pas à télétravailler et le pensent que
leur entreprise est en fonctionnement
car nous avons aussi vu beaucoup
d'entreprises qui petit à petit
réduisent et leur capacité de production
faute de logistique pour
l'approvisionnement parfois faute de
clients parce que quand l'activité
économique générale se ralentit vous
êtes amenés à ralentir votre propre
activité
nous avons des entreprises qui
continuent à fonctionner qui donc
continuer à fonctionner et les salariés
de ces entreprises
dès que leur employeur met en place les
mesures barrières qui permettent
d'éviter la transmission du coronavirus
des distances de sécurité entre les
personnes qui travaillent fais aussi la
mise à disposition de gel hydro
alcoolique ou deux points d'eau pour
pouvoir se laver régulièrement les mains
il est possible de travailler
le confinement que nous mettons en place
il n'interdit pas de travailler il
permet de travailler dès lors que
l'employeur rempli un certain nombre de
conditions qui sont ces fameuses mesures
barrières dont nous souhaitons la mise
en oeuvre à une grande échelle sur tout
le territoire
ailleurs nous aurons faim a mené un
certain nombre de commerces
nous devons fermer son commerce parce
qu'il donne lieu à des rassemblements
inutile de personnes le fait d'aller
faire du shopping dans une grande
enseigne de vente par exemple sur le
boulevard haussmann
en fait ça introduite la promiscuité
entre les individus et donc il faut pas
qu'on faire ses courses et c'est pour ça
que ce type d'enseigné de vente par
exemple de vêtements et fermé le feu ait
pris dans un bar dans un restaurant dans
un lieu festif on de flaumont aussi
parce que ça a introduit la promiscuité
qui n'est pas utile il n'est pas
nécessaire en revanche et interdisons
pas le fait de travailler je voudrais
vous donner quelques exemples que vous
soyez dans une usine qui fabrique de la
glycérine et bien senties série nous ne
pouvons pas fabriquer de gel
hydroalcoolique
donc effectivement nous avons des
chaînes de production qui sont
nécessaires nous avons également des
industries dans lesquelles un arrêt
brutal de la production d'abord n'est
pas possible de même qu'un n'en
sortirons de cette crise est très
difficile s'il y a eu un arrêt complet
aiderait les entreprises sont appelées à
ménager les espaces de travail
lorsqu'elle ne peuvent pas on al houthi
très puissant du chômage partiel pour
venir en aide aux salariés qui
perçoivent ainsi un salaire alors qu'ils
ne peuvent pas travailler mais aussi aux
entreprises puisqu'elles sont
intégralement remboursés de la somme
qu'elles versent à leurs salariés durant
le chômage partiel on a donc un
dispositif dont j'espère qu'à travers
mon intervention
et cette éclaircie on peut continuer à
travailler quand on peut on le fait par
télétravail
quand on ne le peut pas on doit avoir
des mesures barrières qui sont mises en
place par votre employeur pour vous
permet de travailler en toute sérénité
une question sur le conseil des
ministres demain est il envisageable que
ce conseil des ministres active
l'article 16 de la constitution c'est à
dire
plan pouvoir au président élu non ce
n'est absolument pas envisagé une
question maintenant de grégoire
poussière confrères des échos
un infectiologue marseillais affirme que
le courroux navires us peut se guérir
avec de la chloroquine et des
antibiotiques avez vous des informations
à ce sujet le professeur didier raoult
l'hta fait effectivement état de son
souhait d'avoir des essais cliniques
j'explique ce que sont des essais
cliniques ce sont des essais
thérapeutiques qui permettent de tester
un médicament ou une combinaison de
médicaments pour faire pour guérir en
l'occurrence le coronavirus via un essai
clinique sur 24 patients qui a été bonne
et qui donne des résultats effectivement
qui sont plutôt prometteurs et en accord
avec le professeur didier rahout le
ministère de la santé a souhaité que
nous puissions étendre cet essai
clinique
il sera donc étendu mais dans un autre
hôpital avec une équipe indépendante de
celle du professeur out de manière à nos
assurés scientifiquement que ça marche
effectivement sur a beaucoup plus grand
nombre de patients parce que le nombre
24 patients c'est un monde qui est assez
faible et donc toutes les opportunités
thérapeutiques dont les saisies sont et
donc nous permettons de déployer des
essais cliniques y compris à l'échelle
européenne mais je voudrais mettre en
garde tout le monde on se précipite pas
pour aller acheter de la chloroquine
dans les pharmacies maintenant d'abord
parce que quand on prend trop on peut
avoir des conséquences qui sont pas
terribles et ensuite parce que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui la preuve
scientifique que cela fonctionne on a
des débuts prometteurs pour l'essai
clinique a été réalisée à marseille
nous les ponts dont parce que d'un point
de vue scientifique la discipline
scientifique veut que une expérience
pour être valide soit dupliquer
plusieurs fois avant que nous puissions
dire définitivement ça marche ou ça ne
marche pas et dupliqué plusieurs fois ça
veut dire qu'elle d'hélène rousseau mots
doux et bien écouté notamment à lille
l'essai thérapeutique qui a eu lieu à
marseille sera dupliqué sur un plus
grand nombre de patients et au fur à
mesure de l'avancée de lait des constats
que nous ferons sur est-ce que ça
fonctionnerait ce que ça ne fonctionne
pas il y aura des publications qui
seront faites et qui permettront avec
transparence de suivre la progression de
ces essais thérapeutiques une question
plus politique maintenant d'arthur
bernard du
garot dans ces deux allocutions jeudi et
lundi le président a vanté l'état
providence il a promis que l'état payera
et s'est engagé à lutter contre le
coronavirus quoi qu'il en coûte
il a dit vouloir interroger le modèle de
développement dans lequel s'est engagé
notre monde depuis des décennies
d'aucuns y voient un virage social
démocrate cette crise sanitaire
va-t-elle entraîner un virage politique
il y surtout je crois un changement de
paradigme auquel nous devons nous
préparer
je vais vous donner un exemple
aujourd'hui les chaînes de production
industrielle mondiale se déroule aux
quatre coins du monde beaucoup en chine
puisque dans les dernières années la
chine a pris important la fabrication
d'un certain nombre de pièces qui sont
indispensables par exemple pour
fabriquer des voitures dans les usines
françaises
on vous bien que dans cette situation là
on est évidemment nous en difficulté
puisque alors qu'il n'y a pas d'impact
immédiat sur la production de voitures
en france cette production effrénée du
fait de la difficulté d'importation de
machines de parement de pièces pour
fabriquer des voitures de la même
manière on voit bien que en matière
d'industrie mais dans le strip pardon
pharmaceutique
on a un certain nombre de principes
actifs qui sont fabriqués là encore en
chine et le fait que la chine ait stoppé
sa production industrielle conduit à ce
qu'en france on ait des difficultés
on a donc bien là un paradigme celui qui
voulait qu'il y est un éclatement à
l'échelle mondiale des chaînes de
production sans au fond des filets de
sécurité dans les pays eux-mêmes qui
sont les pays de manière fabrication si
j'ose dire
on voit bien ce paradigme la doit
changer sans doute dans d'autres
domaines
est ce que on doit aussi se poser la
question et c'est à cela que nous a
appelé le président la république au
cours de ces deux interventions
j'ai une question maintenant de la
presse étrangère il me semble michaela
wiegel pardon si j'écorche son nom du
café est ce que la france a fait une
demande d'assistance sanitaire à
l'allemagne vu la situation tendue dans
les hôpitaux alsacien il me semble que
c'était envisagé dit elle dans le traité
d'aix la chapelle
alors nous n'avons pas fait de demande
de cette nature à l'allemagne vous le
savez
l'allemagne est elle même confrontée à
une élévation importante du nombre de
ses malades
le prix d'un la république a annoncé le
déploiement d'un hôpital de militaires
de campagne qui sera opéré par le
service de santé des armées dans les
jours à venir en alsace dans le même
temps nous avons examiné ou nous
commencerons je crois assez rapidement à
le faire compte tenu de l'effet de
saturation qui existe actuellement
nous avons examiné les différentes
possibilités pour faire des
rapatriements sanitaires pour un certain
nombre de malades de manière à abaisser
la charge qui aujourd'hui sur les
épaules des soignants en alsace et
globalement dans la région grand test
pour la reporter sur d'autres régions
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas encore
sollicité à ce niveau là une question de
christophe gascard de france info qui
revient souvent on parle d'un
confinement d'une quinzaine de jours
mais concrètement est ce que un
peut être efficace sur une telle
épidémie ou les français doivent-ils
s'attendre à être confiné plus longtemps
et ce qu'on a une vision là dessus alors
ce que nous observons dans d'autres pays
où il y a eu des mesures de cette nature
c'est l'italie notamment qui a eu
l'occasion de le faire et donc
combattons sur l'évolution avec beaucoup
d'attention
on voit que il ya un ralentissement des
nouveaux cas dans les premières zones où
ce type de confinement a été mis en
place
donc ça nous permet d'avoir une
indication intéressante puisqu'il ya à
peu près 15 jours qui se sont écoulés
depuis que ce confinement a été mis en
place c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons fait le choix dans un premier
temps de le mettre en place sur 15 jours
je peux pas garantir aux français qu'eux
ça ne durera que quinze jours et donc il
faut se préparer à ce qu' il est cette
première durée de temps qui a été donnée
mais que nous soyons amenés en fonction
de la situation sanitaire à aller plus
loin
une dernière question bruno le maire a
parlé d'une récession ce matin
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est ce qu'on peut mettre of un pays
et puis après leur maître -on quelques
semaines plus tard comme si rien n'avait
changé
alors ça c'est certain ce n'est
absolument pas possible ce qui est
intéressant ou malheureux si j'ose dire
dans cette crise et qu'on a une crise
contrairement à celle de 2008 qui n'est
pas qu'une crise financière la crise que
nous avons aujourd'hui est une crise qui
touche l'économie réelle
et en particulier qui touche l'autre
puisque c'est l'appareil de production
qui est atteint contenu soit de
l'indisponibilité des salariés soit des
mots à cause de leur maladie éventuel
soit leur indisponibilité du fait des
mesures de confinement et qu'on a là un
choc économique qui est puissant dont
nous mesurons sans doute pas aujourd'hui
à ce stade
l'intégralité des répercussions c'est
pour ça que nous nous y préparons de
manière forte et que nous essayons de
l'amortir au maximum par des mesures qui
peuvent sembler dit mais nous assumons
parfaitement de considérer qu' ils vont
mettre le paquet maintenant pour
protéger et pour sauver ce qui est
sauvable et nous devons encore c'est
déjà de nous poser la question de la
suite il n'y a pas de switch si pour
employer cet anglicisme on peut pas
éteindre l'économie ou la production en
ukraine
elle a allumé si facilement je vous le
disais à l'instant on a des industries
je pense par exemple aux industries qui
sont électro-intensives dons qui sont
très gourmandes en électricité qui ont
beaucoup de mal à s'arrêter et elle se
remettre en match et donc nous savons
aujourd'hui que il ya de véritables
risques qui pèsent sur nos entreprises
notamment les plus petites
notamment les plus fragiles on leur côté
compris quand il s'agit des indépendants
bruno le maire a notamment parlé annoncé
un fonds de solidarité en direction des
petits commerçants et donc on voit bien
là qu'il ya nécessité d'une mobilisation
d'ampleur mais aussi que nous faisons
face à un choc économique qui est quasi
inédit ça coûte très cher à l'état il
pourra s'en relever et je vous le disais
nous devons avoir un changement de
paradigme ça impliquera aussi un
changement de paradigme dans
l'utilisation des deniers publics
merci beaucoup je vous remercie
c'est fait
est ce que j'ai fait beaucoup